The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today we're starting the last
unit of this class, which
is kinetics.
So, we're moving toward the end
of the semester, and today
will just be an introductory
lecture on kinetics.
So, again, kinetics are the
rates of chemical reactions,
and so we're going to talk
about, we're going to
introduce you to rate
expressions and rate laws.
So, when you're considering a
chemical reaction, we've been
asking so far in this class
whether the reaction will go
spontaneously.
So we've been talking a lot
about thermodynamics, we've
been talking a lot
about delta g.
But we also need to consider how
fast a reaction goes, and
that's kinetics.
So, a kinetic experiment is one
in which you measure the
rate at which something's
happening.
The rate at which a
concentration is disappearing
or whether the rate at which
a concentration is forming.
You're measuring some kind of
change of a reaction, change
in composition versus time.
So, I'm going to give, for an
example, of why kinetics are
important talking about the
oxidation of glucose.
And I'm going to ask -- we're
going to do a little
experiment, and I'm going to
ask the TA's to help me.
Everyone needs to have something
to do an experiment
with, something that might have
some glucose in it to do
this experiment.
So, if the TA's could help me
hand out the ingredients for
this experiment.
So, don't open your experimental
apparatus until I
give the OK.
So, just collect it and let me
set up the experiment for you
while we're handing
things out.
So you're all familiar with
this reaction, so we have
glucose and oxygen go
to c o 2 and water.
And so we've talked a lot
about delta g for this
reaction, and delta g again,
is equal to delta h
minus t delta s.
So for this particular reaction,
we have a negative
delta h nought, so what does
negative delta h mean about
this reaction?
It's exothermic.
Delta s nought is positive, what
does that mean, if delta
s nought is positive?
What's increasing?
Entropy or disorder of the
system, which is favorable.
So, our delta g nought is
a big negative number.
So, in terms of thermodynamics,
what does this mean?
Is this reaction spontaneous?
Yes, it's very spontaneous,
it's very
thermodynamically favorable.
Now, when glucose in products
are wrapped, they're often
wrapped under a nitrogen
environment, so, oxygen is not
sealed up in this container,
in the wrapper, and they do
that to prevent bacterial
contamination
and things like that.
So, the glucose that would be
in a wrapped candy is not
exposed to oxygen.
And so if you look at this
thermodynamic information up
here, one might imagine that if
you ripped this open, and
oxygen came in, that there might
be some kind of level of
explosion with c o 2 coming
out and water coming out.
Now, you know, you might say
well, if you have one sort of
little thing it might not, but
now if everyone has one, and
we all open it at the
same time, what do
you expect to happen?
Let's try it.
Oh, we need some
more down here.
Anybody else need any?
All right, so I'm trying mine,
and I'm not really noticing
anything happening.
So the situation is the
following, It is a spontaneous
reaction, but it's slow.
So here, kinetics are
very important.
So, how many of you are having
Thanksgiving with a small
child around, younger siblings
or something like that?
When you see them eat a lot of
sugar, which can happen over
Thanksgiving, it sometimes seems
like an explosion has
occurred, that there's
all of a sudden hyper
energy running around.
But that could be due to this
reaction biochemically,
getting a lot of energy into the
system, but probably you
will not see c o 2 and water
coming off of the small child
as they run around.
So, let me introduce you to
a couple of terms, if you
haven't heard these already.
So people are often talking
about compounds being stable
or unstable.
When they're doing this, they're
talking about the
thermodynamics of a system,
the tendency to decompose,
whether the reaction is
spontaneous or not.
Then you can also hear people
talking about whether the
compound is labile or non-labile
or inert, and this
refers to the rate at which
that tendency is realized.
So you might have a very
unstable compound,
thermodynamically it wants to
decompose, but it also might
be very non-labile, it might
be fairly inert, that
kinetically that decomposition
is going to take such a long
amount of time, that you're
not going to notice the
tendency to decompose.
So, these two can play
off each other.
So, you can have materials
that are very unstable
thermodynamically, but you
won't really see them
decompose because the rate is
just way, way too slow.
So, you know for this particular
reaction, this is
how we get energy -- we make
ATP's of energy for the body.
So it's slow, but in the body we
have to do something about
that because we need energy to
keep going, and so to be a
useful energy source, the
oxidation must be fast enough.
So, does anyone know in the body
what happens to make that
reaction faster?
Enzymes, right.
So, enzymes are catalysts
and they will
speed up the reaction.
So, let me just give
one more example.
Some of you may have heard the
commercial from deBeers, "a
diamond is forever." If you
haven't, you will probably
hear that quite often between
now and the Christmas season.
This is a very popular time, I
guess, for people to buy each
other diamonds.
But if you look at that the
thermodynamics of this,
graphite is actually much
more stable than
diamonds by 2,900 joules.
So, one could argue that
graphite is forever, not that
diamonds are forever.
Of course, here kinetics are
on the side of the diamond,
they're relatively kinetically
inert, it's a huge activation
energy barrier, which we're
going to be talking about in
this unit for the conversion.
So, diamonds do, in fact, stay
around for a long time.
One could still argue that,
perhaps, a better gift would
be a graphite ring than a
diamond ring, but I have a
feeling that probably even if
the person receiving said ring
was a chemist, they might still
not a 100% appreciate
that gesture.
So, it's important, the
thermodynamics are important,
but kinetics are also really
important to understand what
kind of chemical reactions
are going to occur.
So, let's think about what are
some factors that would affect
rates of reactions.
So let's write down, and you can
think about what are some
factors affecting rates.
What's one thing people can
think of that might affect the
rate of a reaction?
STUDENT: Temperature.
PROFESSOR: Temperature,
definitely.
And this is used quite
often in cooking to
get things to occur.
What else affects the
rate of a reaction?
OK, yeah, so pressure could --
if you're changing things,
applying pressure to sort
of switch things around.
That will depend, say, for
pressure on the nature of the
material and things like that of
what you're talking about.
So let's make that a bigger
category and put
nature of the material.
What type of material it is.
And also, along with that, if
you're thinking about a
particular reaction and how it's
going to go and how you
might get it to sort of push one
way or the other, you're
also thinking about the
mechanism of that reaction.
So what's reacting with what
will make a difference.
I think I also heard someone
talk about concentration, how
much of it you have. And you
told me the last one that
we're going to talk about in
this unit, when we were
talking about how the body gets
the oxidation of glucose
to go, what was necessary
there?
A catalyst, right.
So, those are all the things
we're going to talk about in
factors affecting rates of
reaction in this next unit.
So now, chemistry is an
experimental science, and so a
lot of kinetics are involved
with measuring
the rates of reactions.
So let's talk about how
one might measure
the rate of a reaction.
So here's a particular reaction,
we have n o 2 plus
carbon monoxide, going to n o
plus carbon dioxide, and one
could measure the rate of
decrease of the reactants or
the amount of increase
of the products.
So let's just look at
one of the products.
So one might be plotting a
change in the concentration of
one of the products
versus time.
And you may find that it goes
up, and then maybe starts to
level off a little
bit over time.
And now, how are you going to
measure a rate out of this,
the rate at which this
reaction is going?
Well, one could measure an
average rate, which would be
some change in concentration
over some change in
the amount of time.
And you could express that as
the change in concentration
over the change in time.
So, you could pick a particular
interval, say, we
want to measure the average rate
from time is 50 seconds
to time equals 150 seconds, and
we'll look at how much the
concentration has changed
over that time interval.
So, we can do a little
calculation of the average
rate and get a number, 1 .
2 8 times 10 to the minus 4
molar per second, and that's
an average rate.
But if we had picked at
different interval, we would
have gotten a different
number.
So the average rate depends on
the time interval, so that's
not always ideal.
You don't always want to know
an average rate, which might
be different depending on which
particular unit you pick.
So often, when you're talking
about rates, you talk about
instantaneous rates.
So the rate at a particular
instance of time.
And so let's look at
instantaneous rate.
So, we have the same reaction,
same plot, but now we're going
to be considering instead of the
average rate, the rate at
a limit when your time interval
is going to zero --
at a very, very small time
interval, so the rate at the
particular instance.
And so this can be expressed as
d times the concentration
of a product, n o, over d t.
So, as delta t approaches zero,
the rate becomes the
slope of the line tangent to
the point, that particular
time point that you're
interested in.
So, let's find an
instantaneous rate at 150 seconds.
What is the rate of this
reaction at 150 seconds?
So we can look for 150 seconds,
we can have a point
on the curve at 150 seconds.
And so as our time interval
approaches zero, the rate will
approach the slope
of this line.
So we can draw a slope that's
tangent to the curve at the
time t, it's time 150 seconds,
and then we can calculate the
slope of that line.
And so we can do that math,
calculating the slope, and
here we find that at an
instantaneous rate that time
equals 150 seconds, change in
-- this is the slope of the
line -- the change in
concentration over change in
time, and that gives you 7 .
7 times 10 to the minus
5 molar per second.
So, that's instantaneous rate
at a particular time.
What do you think the
instantaneous rate is called
at time equals zero?
Any guess?
Initial rate, yeah.
So, initial rate, instantaneous
rate at time
equals zero seconds.
So that's instantaneous rate.
So now, let's talk about rate
expressions, and then we're
going to talk about rate laws.
So, same equation.
Again, you can monitor how
much your reactants are
disappearing, you can monitor
the amounts of your products
being formed, and you
can express this in
the following way.
So we could say that the rate
is going to be equal to the
decrease in one of the
reactants, so minus d times
the concentration of
n o 2 over d t.
We could also express it in
terms of the second reactant,
so minus d times change in the
concentration of the other
reactant over time.
Or we can express this in terms
of the products being
formed, so here there's no
negative sign, so we have d
concentration of n o over d t,
or our last product, d times
the concentration
of c o 2 d t.
So this would be a rate
expression, and these would
all be equal to each other,
if we make the following
assumption.
We're going to make the
assumption here that there's
no intermediate species that's
being formed, or that if there
are intermediate species, that
their change in concentration
is independent of time.
So if there were some other
really complicated thing going
on here, then those rates may
not be equal and we might have
something else in the mechanism
that would cause one
thing to disappear a lot faster
than something else
that's being formed.
But these should all be equal if
you assume no intermediate
species, or make assumptions
about those
intermediate species.
So, then the general expression
for a rate
expression, if we have an
equation, a plus b going to c
plus d, where we have
coefficients of the reaction,
small a, coefficient small b,
coefficient small c, and
coefficient small d.
So we could express the overall
rate then, minus 1
over a times d a t t minus 1
over b, d b d t, 1 over c, d c
e t, 1 over d d d d d t.
That was not easy.
All right, so that's the general
form for the rate
expression.
So just to make sure that
everyone's on the same page,
why don't you do a
rate expression
for me for this one.
OK, just 10 more seconds.
Excellent.
So you just have to pay
attention to your minus signs,
your stoichiometry.
So, it's minus for the
disappearance, stoichiometry 1
over 2, and then no negatives
for your products of things
that are appearing.
Very good.
Rate expressions, not
that complicated.
All right, so now we're going to
talk about rate laws, which
are slightly more complicated
than rate expressions.
So, a rate law is -- you
come up with a rate law
experimentally, and it's the
relationship between the rate
and the concentration.
So we have -- we're going to
introduce a term called the
rate constant, which is
the small letter k.
And so the rate constant is
going to tell you about the
relationship between the rate
and the concentration of your
reactants in a reaction.
So, if we had that same reaction
here, we could also
write that the rate is equal to
a rate constant times the
concentration of your reactant,
a, raised to a power
m, and b raised to a power n.
So here, m and n are the order
of the reaction with respect
to a and b respectively, so m
is the order of the reaction
in a, and n is the order of
the reaction in b, and our
small letter k here is
the rate constant.
So that would be an expression
for rate law.
And so, now I'm going to tell
you a lot of things that are
true about rate laws.
So, a rate law, again, comes
from experiment, so you can't
just look at the stoichiometry
of the reaction and predict
the rate law.
So m is not the stoichiometry
of the reaction in terms of
the a, that is, unless the
reaction is what we call an
elementary reaction, or a step
in a reaction, and we're going
to talk more about that next
week -- then you can, if it's
an elementary reaction,
then you can use
stoichiometry to predict.
But for other reactions you
can't, and that'll become more
clear next week when we talk
about this in detail.
So, rate laws are not limited
to reactants, sometimes a
product will show up.
It's not that common, but it's
possible, and again, it's
experimentally determined.
So the experiment would have to
tell you whether that term
is going to be there or not.
So, occasionally you'll see a
product term in a rate law.
So, in terms of m and n, the
orders of the reaction, m and
n can be integers, they can be
whole numbers, or fractions,
negative or positive, lots
of options for m and n.
And let me tell you about all
the options for -- we're going
to use m here.
So, you have this table in
your notes, most of it is
blank, some of it is filled in,
and we're going to fill in
the parts that are not
filled in right now.
So we're going to start in the
middle where the order of the
reaction is one here, m equals
1, and that's called a first
order reaction.
So these names are pretty
much intuitive
when you look at them.
So here, the rate law for a
first order reaction would be
our rate constant, k, times
the concentration of a.
So let's think about what that
rate law would mean.
Say you double the concentration
of a, what would
happen to the rate
of the reaction?
How many people say double,
raise your hand.
Good, that's what happens.
All right, so it doubled the
rate of the reaction.
So now let's think
about m equals 2.
See on your handout that that's
called second order --
again these names make sense.
The rate law for this would be k
times the concentration of a
squared, so m equals 2, and
that's shown over here.
If you double the
concentration of
a, what would happen?
So you should quadruple
the rate.
So what about if you tripled
the concentration?
Why don't you go ahead and tell
me if you triple it for m
equals 2, what would
happen to the rate?
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Excellent.
That's right, 9 times.
So, you're definitely getting
the hang of this.
All right, so let's move
down and talk about m
equals minus 1.
If you think of a good name for
this let me know, because
no one ever calls that
anything, so we
can leave that blank.
And go ahead and talk about what
the rate would be there
and how we would write
the rate law.
And so, the rate law, then,
would be k, our rate constant,
times the concentration of
a raised to the minus 1.
All right, if we double the
concentration here, just yell
out what you think
would happen.
You would 1/2 the rate of the
reaction, or you can think
about as 2 to the minus 1, 1/2
the rate of the reaction.
And you will have problems on
problem-set 10, which will be
due a week from Friday where
you're going to be given
experimental data, and you have
to look at it and see,
OK, what happened to the rate,
and then what does that mean
about the order of
the reaction.
So this is a lot of what
the problems are
like in this unit.
All right, also there is no
name that I'm aware of for
when n equals minus 1/2, but
we can write the rate law.
So that's just going to be k
times the concentration of a
raised to the minus 1/2 --
again, for the order of
reaction, they can be integers,
they can be
fractions, they can
be negative,
and they can be positive.
So, tell me for doubling the
concentration here of this
one, what's going to
happen to the rate?
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Yup, so most people
got that right.
So, if we go back here, 0 .
7 times the rate, you could
think about this as 2 raised
to the minus 1/2.
These get a little more
complicated and are some of
the harder ones on the
problem-set to recognize the
relationship.
So if you remember all the
possibilities, it's going to
help you think about what's
going on when you see the
experimental data.
All right, so let's go up to m
equals 1/2 here, and this one
sometimes does have a name --
anyone want to guess what that
one might be called?
Half order, very good.
So, half order, and so here our
rate, then, is going to be
equal to k times a to the 1/2.
So, if we double the
concentration here, what
happens to the rate?
Someone want to yell it out?
So, 1 .
4 times the rate.
And m equals 0 -- any guess
of what that's called?
Zero order.
And the rate law here,
the rate is going
to be equal to what?
K, and that's it.
So the rate equals k.
So what does that mean -- if you
double the concentration,
what happens to the rate?
Yup, no effect on rate.
So that's zero order -- the
concentration term, it doesn't
matter what the concentration
is, and there will be some
that you'll see on a problem-set
like that, so if
there's no effect on rate,
you have a zero order.
So those are the possibilities
that you will see for the
order of reactions, and again,
you'll be given experimental
data and have to figure out the
order of the reactions.
And often, it's not just as
simple as one thing, there'll
probably be two things in
there, so you'll have to
figure out the order with
respect to both
of those two things.
So that makes it a little
more complicated.
All right, a couple more
things that are
true about rate laws.
So the overall reaction order
is this sum of the exponents
in the rate law.
So then, if you had this rate
law, rate equals k times a to
the 2, second order, and
b 1, the overall order
for this would be?
3.
So, we have third order.
Sum of 2 plus 1.
So for this particular one, your
second order with respect
to a, first order with respect
to b, third order overall.
Units.
Units for k are a lot of fun.
So it depends on what the
reaction is, and often, for a
problem, you'll have to figure
out what the units for k are,
depending on are we talking
about molar per second or
what's going on.
So just pay attention to the
units for k, they can vary.
And sometimes one of the
problems will be what are the
units for this particular k, so
you'll have to figure that
out per problem.
So now, again, kinetics is
experimental -- we determine
rate laws experimentally, and
sometimes this is not easy,
because sometimes there'll be
very small changes that you're
looking at, or those changes
will happen really quickly, so
the interval of time
is very short.
And sometimes when you're
trying to measure these
changes, the reaction's
happening faster than your
equipment can record
those changes.
So this can be technically very
difficult, and so one
thing that scientists do is they
use integrated rate laws.
So in this way, you can
express concentrations
directly as a function of time
and you don't have to worry so
much now about measuring those
small amounts of changes that
occur are very, very quickly.
So let's talk about integrated
rate laws.
And here, we're going to start
a derivation of an
integrated rate law.
So here's -- we're told this is
a first order reaction, and
so we're going to do the first
order integrated rate law.
And in this reaction, a is going
to b -- we can write a
rate expression for this.
so we can talk about the
disappearance minus
d a over d t.
We can also now write the rate
law for a first order
reaction, and we know that that
is our rate constant,
small k, times the concentration
of a.
So we know we can write the rate
expression, and we can
write a rate law for this
first order reaction.
So now, we can do
a derivation.
So, in this derivation, we're
going to separate our
concentration terms and our time
terms. So we're going to
move everything with
concentration to one side, and
things with time to
the other side.
So, on one side, then, we can
have 1 over the concentration
of a, we're going to bring
that down here.
We have d a over here, and
then we have our negative
sign, and our k over here, and
move d t also over to the
other side.
So now we have concentration
terms on one side and time
terms on the other side.
And now, as you might have
guessed from the name
integrated rate laws, we can
integrate, and so we can look
at the interval from the initial
concentration or
original concentration of
a, to concentration of a
at some time, t.
And we can also look at from
some time, 0, to the time, t,
in question.
So there's that expression
again.
Now you can write this
expression also in terms of
natural log.
So we can re-write this in terms
of the natural log of
the concentration of a at time,
t, minus the natural log
of the concentration of a at
our original time, or the
original concentration,
equals minus k t.
And you can also express it in
this term, so you can just
bring this guy over to the other
side of the equation,
and this is one expression for
the integrated rate law that
you will see.
There's also another expression
that you'll see,
and let's show you
what that is.
So you can also take the natural
log and bring these
two terms together.
So natural log of your
concentration of a at time t,
over your original concentration
of a
equals minus k t.
And now you can take the inverse
natural log of both
sides, so just your
concentration at time t over
your initial concentration
equals e to the minus k t.
And that expression is often
written in your book or on
equation sheets as a
concentration at a particular
time equals the concentration of
the original material, e to
the minus k t.
And these are the two
expressions that you'll see
the most often.
This one is often referred to as
your integrated first order
rate law, whereas this
one is the equation
for a straight line.
So these two are the ones that
you will see the most often
for integrated first
order rate laws.
So one was an equation for a
straight line, so let's come
up with a straight line.
So if you plot your data,
if you've measured your
concentration of a at various
times, you can take the
natural log of those
concentrations that you
measured and plot them
against time.
And if you do this, and it is,
in fact, a first order
reaction, you should get
a straight line.
So here, we can look at this in
terms of a straight line,
so on y-axis, we have the
natural log of the
concentration of a at a
particular time, and that's
plotted against time, over
here in seconds.
And so, what does that mean in
terms of what is this, what is
the intercept here?
Yup.
So the natural log of your
initial original
concentration of a.
And what is the slope
of this line?
The slope is negative k, and
so the slope is really what
people are after.
So often what you want to do is
measure rate constants for
particular reactions, and if
you can then measure the
concentration of a at particular
times and plot it
this way, you can come out
with your rate constant.
And that's what you want to
know, and those are some of
the problems that you're
going to see.
Are you going to see
experimental data for what
happens to rate at particular
concentrations, and you can
come up with values for
your rate constants.
So, let's talk about one other
thing, which is half life.
So people are often very
concerned with half life.
When do you hear about
half life a lot?
Does anyone know?
Yeah, when we talk about
radioactivity, which we'll be
talking about next class.
They're very concerned about
the half life, which is the
time it takes for the full
amount of your original
material to be reduced
by a 1/2.
So we can look at an equation
that we had up above for our
integrated first order half
life, and we can think about
this in terms of a half
life expression.
So here, t has a particular
special meaning -- we have t,
1/2, which is the abbreviation
for half life.
And so half life by definition
is the amount of time it takes
for the original concentration
to be reduced by 1/2.
So here we have our final
concentration, concentration
of a at a time t.
So when we're talking about half
life, we're going to have
1/2 as much as we had
when we started.
So our a t is going to be our
original divided by 2, 1/2 the
amount we had in
the beginning.
And so, now t has a special
name, it's t to the 1/2 here.
So now we can simplify this
expression to come up with an
expression for half life for
a first order reaction.
So, the a to the 0, our original
concentrations cancel
out, and so we have the natural
log of 1/2 equals
minus k, our rate constant,
times t 1/2.
The natural log of
1/2 is minus 0 .
6 9 3 1.
We can get rid of our negative
signs and solve for t 1/2,
because this is a half
life expression, so t
1/2 equals 0 .
6 9 3 1 over k.
So that's an expression just for
a first order half life.
And notice that half life
does not depend on
concentration here.
That term dropped out.
So half life depends on our
rate constant, k, and k
depends on the material
in question.
So, for radioactive material,
some radioactive materials
have short half lifes, so their
k's are very different
from each other, and so that
can be very important,
especially when you're thinking
about storing
radioactive waste.
So, using that value, tell me,
for the same material then,
does it take longer to go from
1 ton to a 1/2 ton, or from 1
gram to 1/2 gram?
Let's just take 10
more seconds.
Yup, it takes the same
amount of time.
And then just to finish up here,
we have one more thing
to do and then we're done.
So here, in a plot for a first
order half life, the
concentration of the material
at the first half life has
dropped by how much?
1/2.
At the second half
life is what?
STUDENT: 1/4.
PROFESSOR: And the
third half life?
STUDENT: 1/8
PROFESSOR: Yup, so that's
first order half life.
All right, everybody, have
a happy Thanksgiving.